let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
well happy cinco de mayo
may 5th welcome to let's talk the tony
michaels podcast
there's some news today that i'd like to
talk about
so let's do some talking shall we
[Music]
so you guys have probably heard that the
facebook oversight committee
oversight board the supreme court of
facebook
told donald trump to go [ __ ] himself
no you cannot be back on our platform
this temporary ban that they have it
will remain
temporary for another six months so
we're going to talk about that today
delete facebook and of course we're
going to talk about cheeto
cheeto jesus the mango mussolini
the orange deity the former guy
donald j trump himself and how he
started his
own social media platform i mean it's a
blog but
they want to call it a social media
platform so we're going to talk about
that
and because he got banned and because
now he has a blog
uh you know these nin kapoop nazi
conservatives out there are really
confused about what the first amendment
actually is and how it works not
surprising that they don't know this
and they don't know that social media is
capitalism
that's not surprising either and we're
going to talk about big
tech breaking up big tech big tech
algorithms
everyone wants to blame facebook blame
tick tock
blame twitter and the algorithms and
somehow it's brainwashing people
so we're going to talk about both sides
of the algorithm today so we're going to
talk about all those
sorts of things so stay tuned here
because we got a lot of stuff to get to
a lot
so we have this facebook supreme court
the oversight committee
decides that the ban that facebook
placed on donald j
trump from back what happened on january
6. if you remember
um and and i actually did a video when
when twitter banned him but not
exactly when facebook banned him but it
all kind of happened at the same time
but it was all over this january 6 in
him inciting violence and him
trying to attempt a coup he was trying
to overthrow the government of the
united states
that's what happened so he did a couple
videos on facebook
uh he had a post and it posted on
twitter and of course
the video posted on twitter too and it
was all for everyone to see
basically giving no apology to what
happened on january 6th and
cheering on his manga q and on trump
bumpers
cheering them on now i mean later on he
said
that it wasn't them it was antifa
dressed in in their clothes
and then now now it's oh these people
are fantastic
these insurrectionists are fantastic
they're just normal average people
they're not really seditious or
treasonous they're just normal average
people that went to overthrow the
government
so they continue to move the goal post
and change the narrative
which is not surprising with these
[ __ ] fascists
but that's what they do that is what
they do
folks so uh
what happened is is you know they
basically decided yeah you're still
banned [ __ ]
and uh the manga universe the q anon
manga trump pumping universe
uh lost their [ __ ] minds and they
decided that they would get
the hashtag delete facebook trending uh
it was trending on twitter
and i'm sure that uh they were over on
facebook uh i seen uh patriot takes
there's a shout out to
at patriot takes on twitter uh he they
were saying today that
uh that they're on facebook
saying that they wanna they're cheering
on the
the fall of facebook on facebook
and on parlor
again i i don't understand why these
people don't
get the first amendment they don't
understand that social media is
capitalism they don't understand that
these
that these social media platforms are
companies and websites that they don't
own
these are not public forums as like it's
a public utility
they're not it's not like public radio
or public tv
that's not what it is these are this is
private industry capitalism
now i understand that most of these
[ __ ] idiots
don't actually like or understand how
capitalism works i completely understand
it being a capitalist myself
i know they don't understand that type
of [ __ ]
you can tell just by their arguments
that they make
that they're [ __ ] boneheads and
they're they're corporate fascists
they're not capitalist now again
if you have to go look these [ __ ]
words up if you got to go look these
phrases up and what they are
fantastic but if you haven't figured
this [ __ ] out yet
if you haven't figured this [ __ ] out yet
then you're behind the ball
social media companies
are private companies and they own the
website
they own it it's their property
just like let's give an example
that all you bone-headed redneck
toothless manga q and on [ __ ] will
understand
and i know you go to walmart even though
it's on the boycott list
you go to walmart because it's probably
where
q anon has their monthly meetings i
don't know
i don't know where you nazis meet
just on facebook i guess but we'll get
into that here in a little bit
but let's say you decide you
hate you some walmart
hate it or let's decide you're gonna use
walmart's property
their store to send a message because
you know
walmarts are really big and they got
really big walls
and you could paint some really big
[ __ ] words
on the side of the wall at walmart and a
lot of people would see it
so let's just say for a minute that you
walk in walmart you buy some
paint you walk outside walmart
and you might want to get a ladder too
some
paint brushes maybe some rollers maybe
some masking tape
i don't know how good of an artist you
are probably not that great
but let's say you wanted you wanted to
paint hashtag delete facebook
on the side of walmart's wall because
you're allowed to walk in there you're
allowed to buy
things you're allowed to stand on the
sidewalk and talk to people and have a
conversation
you can sell your girl scout cookies
outside
the walmart you can ring the bell
for the salvation army surely you can
paint
you can paint lies on the side of
walmart's wall
for everyone to see surely they won't
call the police on you and have you
arrested because you're
vandalizing their property
now just like that store that physical
[ __ ] building
is the property or rented property of
walmart facebook.com and their app
is their private [ __ ] building it's
their
property they have rules
and guidelines to tell you what you can
and cannot do
on their [ __ ] property that's how it
[ __ ] works
they own it they own it
so you don't get to go [ __ ]
paint all over the side of facebook lies
especially if it breaks their guidelines
and then when they do tell you to get
the [ __ ] off their property and never to
come back
they get to decide when and with if and
when you can come back
that's what happened today it's called
[ __ ] capitalism
there's a profit motive for facebook
folks it's not a [ __ ] public forum a
cork
board down at the [ __ ] the goddamn
senior center
it's not
it is their website it is their app
it is their platform they
own it and when donald trump decided to
get on facebook
before he well he's always spread lies
but before he
spread the lie of january 6 and the
reason why they booted him off that
[ __ ]
he clicked i agree to the terms and
conditions of this website
and he broke them and they said [ __ ] you
you broke the terms and conditions
and they're upholding their ban now this
ban is only for another six months
and apparently this decision has all
kinds of [ __ ] wrapped in it everyone
wants to make it so simple that they
banned him for life and that's not what
the [ __ ] they did
they they extended this ban for the next
six months for facebook to do their
evaluation
and they gave them suggestions on rules
and guidelines to change those rules and
guidelines to
nip it in the butt and make sure
everything was buttoned up that way of
donald trump which he probably will
end up back on facebook at some point
has new rules and guidelines to that he
will agree to those terms and conditions
and more than likely he will break them
and it's probably likely that facebook
won't do a [ __ ] thing about it
because really at the end of the day
facebook cares about one thing
selling advertising and the only way to
sell advertising
on their little virtual highway is to
have eyeballs on their virtual highway
so whatever creates those virtual
eyeballs to their
space that's what they want so they can
sell their
it's a literally you got to think of
facebook as
as a a highway with a bunch of
billboards here in missouri i live in
missouri so there's a lot of [ __ ]
billboards
because forever there really was no
legislation or regulation of billboards
and where they were at and
how big they were and how many there
were there are more now
because they're [ __ ] everywhere when
you drive down the highway
that's what facebook is folks it's a
[ __ ] highway
and it feeds you billboards that's the
profit motive that they chose to take
when they monetize the platform
instead of like a subscription service
like netflix
which is also a platform that they get
to choose
whose content is on their platform
and no one just you can't just go post
your [ __ ] on netflix
you can't because their guideline says
no we have to post the [ __ ]
on there and we have a subscription
service so our folks can watch the [ __ ]
on our platform
that's how [ __ ] works capitalism
jesus [ __ ] christ i can't even
believe i can't even believe that in
2021
i have to sit here on a [ __ ] podcast
yelling into a microphone
having to explain to people who claim to
be free market capitalist
what [ __ ] capitalism actually is
it it's [ __ ] mind-boggling
that we're at this point that you
[ __ ] are so goddamn
dumbed down by this [ __ ] orange deity
of yours
that you don't even know not only do you
not know what capitalism is
you have no idea what the [ __ ] first
amendment is
you have no clue no
[ __ ] clue at all which leads me to my
next
point the next thing i want to talk
about
is so he got banned from all the social
media platforms
the only one that will allow him to even
be on their platform is
parlor which is a kind of a joke at this
point now apparently they're going to
come back
online to some of the app stores
eventually
uh i i doubt it it gets any kind of legs
because they they
they are very well known not to moderate
their [ __ ] platform and that's been
the the
the the conditions of them
re-entering some of those app stores
that they have to [ __ ] moderate
which facebook does a shitty job at
moderating too
i mean they have enough money they could
hire moderators from
it would create hundreds of jobs
thousands of jobs in this country to
have moderators but they don't not the
amount that they probably should
and we're going to talk about the
algorithm here in a second how you know
people feed you lines
from the left and the right about how
the algorithm is a bad guy it's not the
algorithm we'll talk about that here in
a minute
but donald j trump decides to
add a little blog to his website he
calls it a social media platform which
i mean the only thing you can do is
actually share the [ __ ] thing as far
as i can see
you can't comment so that that means you
can't leave a nasty note for
him because you know you would hurt his
sensitivity that [ __ ]
[ __ ] whiny little [ __ ]
but he he he he's creating a blog
is essentially what it is and and
uh i did a video today on tick tock and
maybe i should play it here real quick
uh it talks about the uh uh having the
that he's a blog why don't we do that
and then i'll talk about him being a
blogger oh the former guy is gonna be a
blogger
let's let's let's do that social court
let's talk today facebook upholds her
temporary ban on donald j
trump
what's this [ __ ] gonna do start
a blog
he's gonna be a blogger what the [ __ ]
can you imagine trying to have to
explain what a blog is to this dumb
[ __ ] jesus
[ __ ] christ these two non-manga dumb
bucks our butt hurt over this band
and can't stop crying over it you
[ __ ] snowflakes
the same people that would have been
pissed off at the results of the
nuremberg trials
you [ __ ] nazis of course people like
charlie kirk lauren borbert and marjorie
taylor green
are gonna take this leftist facebook all
the way to the supreme court
you think facebook is a leftist group
what [ __ ] planet do you people
live on facebook [ __ ] trump and [ __ ]
these snowflake
ninka poop nazis oh yeah and [ __ ] your
feelings too
[ __ ] them [ __ ] your feelings too
[ __ ] em i mean
uh they sure are triggered to the [ __ ]
your feelings
crowd sure is triggered today uh you
know they want to get off facebook and
delete facebook
and and destroy facebook [ __ ] facebook
while they're posting on facebook
but anyway so the former guy the orange
deity the cheeto jesus the mango
mussolini
started a blog and and literally you
know normally when you start a blog
you're like ah these things are gonna be
three
four hundred words hail to the no hell
to the no this is just a cheap ass
twitter feed is all this is
on his website a cheap ass twitter feed
and that's maybe what he should have
called it was
donaldj ass trump.com feed
i don't know maybe i think it's called
from the desk of donald j
trump or some [ __ ] but uh you can like
it you can't unlike it
you can't give it a thumbs down there's
no angry face
you can share it on other social media
platforms of course because that's
really the intent
which i don't even know how they
couldn't figure out how that was gonna
happen
how did they not know that they could
start a blog and share the [ __ ] blog
post to other social medias
i mean it's taken think about this this
[ __ ] has not been present since
january 20th he's been
banned from twitter for longer than that
and they haven't figured out yet that
you can just post up a blog post online
and share it on twitter they had no
[ __ ] clue
that's how long it took them to get here
holy [ __ ] and if you've seen
screenshots because i haven't gone on
the website i just seen screenshots of
it because i don't give a [ __ ] really
if he has a blog or if he has a video
vlog
or if he does a food vlog or he whatever
the [ __ ] he decides that he wants to do
if he wants to do
box box unboxings and reviews who gives
a [ __ ] i mean he's doing open mics at
weddings
so what the [ __ ] does it matter what
he's doing on his goddamn blog or his
vlog or whatever the [ __ ] he wants to
call it
his social media platform social media
for who for you
and how he didn't figure this out and
and how people aren't surprised that
this is what this is the
evolution into donald trump's social
media strategy
because this is how he treated twitter
he just went on twitter and just posted
a bunch of garbage and left
he's going to do the same thing with the
blog he's going to post a bunch of
garbage within 120 characters and he's
going to leave
he doesn't give a [ __ ] and people are
going to share it all over twitter
so it's going to be like he's tweeting
duh why they didn't figure this out i
have no idea
if i mean [ __ ] it's not that complicated
but here we are here we are
with the orange deity with his little
with his little
website his little fake social media
platform that he thinks is cool
all right go ahead post some dumb
[ __ ] just like he and and and this is a
dick contest really this is what really
pisses him off the reason why he wants
to be on twitter so goddamn bad
is because barack obama and joe biden
now have more followers than he has
because he has zero zero followers on
twitter because he doesn't have an
account it's gone poof
gone and they want to be back on
facebook and the reason why they want to
be back on facebook is because they know
that's where
all this q anon mogadi these [ __ ]
trump humpers live
this misinformation lives very well
on facebook like there's all kinds of
[ __ ] nooks and cranny on facebook for
this [ __ ] to
get spread and they find it they shut it
down then they
open it back up so they can spread it
everywhere
on on on facebook because facebook
really i mean if anyone's disappointed
that facebook would close down i mean i
[ __ ] let them delete facebook as far
as i'm concerned
i mean what is facebook for other than
to get rid of the garbage that you
couldn't sell at the garage sale
and to listen to your aunt sal and your
uncle ned [ __ ] about misinformation
and cueing on [ __ ] and maybe i mean it
used to be for [ __ ] cat pictures and
cat videos but we can't even get to that
point anymore now
we can't even get a [ __ ] good cat
meme on facebook
it's all got to be this manga queueing
on trump pumping [ __ ]
that's why i'm really not on facebook
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
so we have that and then and then of
course
of course because because they think
when they hear the word ban you know
it's cancelled culture of course
they want to cancel liz cheney this week
but when but when facebook doesn't allow
donald trump to post a post on
[ __ ] facebook that that's cancer
culture but getting rid of liz cheney
that's not cancer culture boycotting
coca-cola in the mlb
that's not cancel culture that's
boycotting well just look at it this way
you [ __ ] morons
you [ __ ] [ __ ] eating morons
facebook is boycotting donald j trump
there you go that make it easier for you
[ __ ] bonehead
that clear it up for you a bit
good lord so we have people like charlie
kirk
uh lauren beaubert
marjorie taylor green lauren lauren
bobert really uh is off the deep end
here on twitter uh this morning really
showing
the the that she's a true fascist
and that she believes in corporate
fascism not capitalism
uh they want to take the deceit
it's it's hard to even say because you
gotta think that these people at some
point are joking
are they they can't even take themselves
seriously because this is such a [ __ ]
joke
they actually they actually think that
the
the facebook oversight board is somehow
connected to the federal court system
and somehow this federal oversight or
this this facebook oversight board
is going to ascend its way into the
federal court up to the supreme court
and the supreme court is going to make a
decision
what the you delusional [ __ ]
how how in the [ __ ] you you couldn't
even get a goddamn
halfway decent court case to the supreme
court to try to overturn the election
that joe biden won
it ain't no [ __ ] wonder you're so
goddamn twisted up in your brain
you don't even know that the facebook
oversight
board has nothing to do with federal
court system
and their decision doesn't go to the
supreme court
like you people have this twisted
delusional idea what the supreme court
is
it's no wonder you put so much faith
into how you're gonna control people
with the supreme court
i mean they're completely terrified of
the supreme court
that democrats democrats are gonna pack
the court like we did
and it's gonna control you and it's
gonna ruin society
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i mean yeah we're gonna pack the court
like you pack the cord that's how it
works
i mean i think we should change that
[ __ ] to where
politics can't pack courts that that
politics and and policy
and ideology doesn't pack the courts
you pack the courts with judges like
actual judges
not political favors but i mean yeah
whatever i mean i think we should change
it to be
that
[ __ ] boneheads but they think
charlie kirk lauren boober believe
that donald trump was wrong and the only
way to right a wrong for donald trump
is to go to the supreme court because he
picked him and they'll
they'll side with him because he picked
them
and they owe him favors that's how it
works that's how fascism works
i mean not fascism i didn't mean that
it's where we're at
it's where we're at and and you know
this is this is fantastic
because they're flailing here they're
flailing i mean i mean they're trying to
actually get rid of liz cheney
as the conference chair in the house of
representatives
they booed mitt romney and damn near
centered mitt romney in utah
you tall oh my you [ __ ] kidding me
the utah republican party booed and
almost censored
mitt romney like mr mormon himself
almost got censored by the utah
republican party
they want to cancel and boycott liz
cheney and mitt romney susan collins
lisa murkowski
anyone anyone who would say anything bad
about their orange deity
even if it's true especially if it's
[ __ ] true
by god if it's true cancel that
[ __ ]
which brings me to uh because because
you know this is all part of the big lie
and then that's why they want to get rid
of romney and liz cheney's
because they're out there saying hey
this election
fraud [ __ ] how he won the election and
joe biden didn't that's all [ __ ]
that's all of that's [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] real
stop believing that garbage it's not
[ __ ] real
and that's that's what pisses them off
because they want to keep selling this
big lie thing
and the reason why they want to sell the
big lie and i've talked about this
before is they want donald trump to
carry the water
of election fraud so that they can
[ __ ] change laws
to suppress the vote and the best bucket
to carry that
to to carry that [ __ ] in is the big lie
that's the best bucket to carry it in
and they're gonna let donald trump carry
this bucket they're gonna use him he
doesn't know that
he doesn't know that he's irrelevant and
they don't give a [ __ ]
but they don't give a [ __ ] all they care
about is their power that's all they
cared about when trump was in power
anyways was their power
they don't give a [ __ ] and he's down at
mar-a-lago doing open mics at weddings
thinking that they're gonna back him on
this effort
to overturn the election as if this
[ __ ] audit in arizona is gonna
overturn it even if
even if on some other [ __ ] planet and
some other goddamn alternate universe
that the audit in arizona turns out to
overturn the election
in arizona and gives it to trump number
one
they've already certified the results
it's already
done it's over with there's no there's
no undoing it
you can't undo it number one
number two even if you got the results
are overturned so even if you
you you proceed with the delusion that
that somehow there were fraudulent votes
and there was water marks or whatever q
and on [ __ ] conspiracy theory that
you want to [ __ ] believe
which by believing it doesn't make it
believing it anymore doesn't make it any
more of the truth
and somehow if you get to that part of
the delusion where you're in that phase
where you actually get someone to
consider overturning it and they do
even if you overturn the electoral votes
in arizona that is still
not enough for donald trump to be the
president of the united states
like you you people literally keep
moving the goal post in positions where
it's not even possible for him to win
like why would you do that well
you'd think if you'd have some sort of a
delusion some [ __ ] story
that that [ __ ] story at the end of
the road
that it would accomplish the goal you
want to accomplish
but they're cheering oh i mean i've seen
in the comments
i've seen these you know these these
trumpers these
be triggered in the comments
by saying oh you're just scared of the
audit in arizona
number one it's all [ __ ] and all you
gotta do is see the people who's
running it to know that that they're
full of [ __ ] they always have been
always have been full of [ __ ] always
will be full of [ __ ]
and that even if they overturned it even
if they did what you say they're going
to do it's not going to make a [ __ ]
that's a difference in the first place
in two different ways number one it's
already done it's already certified it's
in law
they've voted on it the law it's
enshrined
legally number two
number two it's not even enough
electoral votes to overturn the election
even if that's what you wanted to do
in some sort of alternate universe where
this is december of 2020.
it's like i don't know i guess we're
gonna hop in the delorean and go
get up to 88 miles an hour and go back
and change the election results from
arizona because
we've got water marks on ballots or some
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about
i mean when your entire when your entire
election
uh overturning uh an election
depends on back to the future type time
travel [ __ ] you are in [ __ ] trouble
my friend
you are in [ __ ] trouble holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys like my new my new toy
so there's the election
the the
the arizona audit
that's gonna give us the overturning
and trump even mentioned this he
mentioned this at his open mic session
at a wedding about a week ago
and uh of course you know i had a little
commentary on it
and this is i actually it turned out to
be one of my uh favorite videos that
i've ever done
really it has um i i i love this video
and i don't know what it is about it but
i'm gonna play it for you guys here
and then we're gonna talk about his
little open mic session on the other
side
so here you go have you ever noticed
that former presidents normally retire
with some [ __ ] dignity and don't do
open mics at
weddings get a [ __ ] clue you whiny
little
[ __ ] [ __ ] them
so there's not a lot to unpack
usually there's a lot to unpack with my
videos but there's not a lot there
uh apparently there's a wedding donald
trump gets up he decides to he sees a
microphone
and he runs to the microphone and he
stands there like he's some kind of
animatronic chuck e cheese type
character
and he starts to say the same old [ __ ]
can't even come up with a new goddamn
line can't have come up with a new
goddamn idea same old [ __ ] same old
[ __ ]
on on on the big big lie in election
fraud and somehow he won and
arizona is going to overturn it and i
don't know
but he doesn't he does an open mic
session there at the wedding
and that's what he's doing now he's been
relegated to
you know standing in front of 20 people
yapping in front of a microphone
bitching i guess he i guess he's
practicing his new
his new speech i don't know i don't know
but it is very apparent that he's not
running in 2024.
like this this is evidence
and if i've ever seen evidence of
someone not running
this is it folks this is it
him living in his own hotel think about
this
he's living in his own hotel his own
private hotel country club he's living
there
and he's going to the open mics and
crashing the weddings at night to m.c
the weddings on the stage in front of 20
30 people
and he started a blog
he started a blog
that this is the this is the the
evidence
that he's not running he's not going to
run in 2024
and how how they don't see this what
which
they do see it like the republicans
mitch mcconnell kevin mccarthy all the
leaders
liz cheney why do you think liz jady's
saying what she's saying
liz cheney is is is not an ally here
as far as democrats and liberals are
concerned [ __ ] liz cheney
i liz cheney can go kick rocks for all
i'm concerned and
i i hope as far as as far as ideology
their party
and and and for for congress they do
crucify her
and she doesn't and she they force her
to leave the party
[ __ ] them that is to their detriment not
hers
there that that is only a sign that
they're almost done
that they're dying out on the limb when
they can't keep a liz cheney in their
party
because she she's telling the truth
because she wants corporate money
because let's be honest she's not
telling the truth because she's some
sort of [ __ ]
she's some sort of [ __ ] truth hero
give me a [ __ ] break
this is liz cheney we're talking about
here
the moral compass of a cheney give me a
[ __ ] break
the only reason why it seems like that
liz cheney is a moral hero here
is because she's on the opposite side of
donald trump
that's an easy way to look like a moral
[ __ ] hero
an easy way it's not that difficult
but the enemy of your enemy is not
always your [ __ ] friend
and liz cheney is no friend to liberal
ideas and liberal government she's not
she won't be just because she's trump
enemy
but she's trump and trump's enemy right
now for a [ __ ] reason
and the reason is is the corporate
coffers are drying up
and the reason why the corporate coffers
are drying up is because they remember
and they know history these people who
run these companies are [ __ ] educated
they understand history they know what
happened in
germany in the 1930s and the 1940s
they're not dumb they know what fascism
breeds in capitalist society it breeds
corporate fascism
and you will not survive
so you're got to make a [ __ ] choice
and they're making choices
because they see the writing on the wall
they see the fascists taking over the
republican party and it's not like
it's not like thin veiled fascism like
they had for [ __ ] decades
where they talked about debts and
deficits and
deregulation and big government that's
all that was all [ __ ] thin bail
conservative [ __ ]
now i'll give you that there are some
conservative ideologues
in this country
but the majority of that [ __ ] was
all thin veiled fascism
all of it the entire [ __ ] [ __ ] in
caboodle supply side economics
trickle down it's all
thin bale fascism all of it
all of it
and if you boneheads out there you
fascist don't understand what corporate
fascism is
don't understand what happened in
germany in the 1930s and 1940s
look at the [ __ ] up look at the [ __ ] up
and if you still can't manage to go over
to the google machine and look up the
[ __ ]
well there is a there is a goddamn
documentary out there from 1977.
it's called hitler a career go watch it
it's not some kind of liberal [ __ ]
rag that made that [ __ ] documentary
this is from 1977
go watch hitler a career i believe it's
on amazon or netflix
go watch it and if and if you're a
bonehead and you boycott netflix and
amazon well you're just [ __ ] anyways
hitler a career it's a documentary from
1977.
it's not some kind of [ __ ] liberal
rag that made that documentary
go watch it jesus i can't even believe i
have to point to this stuff to you
people
[ __ ]
now for the people who have a half a
brain who aren't
[ __ ] maga boneheads
these people are not gonna understand
this stuff they're not
they think communism and fascism is the
same goddamn thing
they think we fought communism in world
war two because
nazis are the national socialist party
and socialists are coming to get this
[ __ ] all
[ __ ] turned around and confused in
their delusional little
spider web of a brain that they've got
they can't put the marbles together
never will they won't
but here's who will people who run
corporations in this country
they can put two facts together jam them
together and go oh that's a fact
sandwich we're gonna eat it
oh this fact sandwich tastes like we
shouldn't
go down the road of fascism because it
appears to be that's what the
republicans are trying to do
when they're trying to have a america
first caucus
their own nazi party inside [ __ ]
inside [ __ ] congress with marjorie
taylor green mac
lauren bobert mo brooks these [ __ ]
nazis
of course corporate america sees where
this is going
they see exactly where this is going
that's why they're not giving them money
especially
when part of this idea came to fruition
on january
6 with the insurrection
that's why liz cheney's doing what she's
doing
is because she wants corporate money and
she wants republicans to have corporate
money
what she wants because she knows that
the cult of trump is not sustainable
the cult of debts and deficits and
deregulation and big governments the
enemy
that's more sustainable she understands
that
she understands the corporations in this
country will buy that [ __ ] line of
fascism
she gets it she knows
history and she knows you can't just
sell full-on [ __ ] fascism right out
in the open it doesn't work very well
that's why eight million more people
voted for joe biden
not because they'd like joe biden
because they didn't want fascism
it's pretty [ __ ] simple it's not
complicated
it's not and it doesn't matter what the
[ __ ] you believe
you can keep believing all this nonsense
that joe biden and president and
donald trump's going to be president and
the arizona audit and all this garbage
and all this [ __ ]
you can believe it all day long to your
heart's content it doesn't make it true
it doesn't make it more true to believe
this [ __ ]
just like the way you believe the first
amendment is your right to post anything
you want whenever
you want because you're a conservative
and you're a republican democrats they
should shut their [ __ ] mouths
at lebron james that colin kaepernick
just play
basketball would you would you just play
basketball and football and shut your
mouth
oh really so they have to shut their
mouth
idiots [ __ ] boneheads they're not
going to get it they're not going to get
what the sec
the first amendment says they're not
gonna get it i mean date
i i'm gonna play a video here because i
did a [ __ ]
have you ever noticed
because they literally yell and scream
about two goddamn amendments and they
don't even understand those two [ __ ]
amendments and it's very
clear that they don't understand those
amendments
josh hawley ted cruz are all whining
about it donald trump
[ __ ] kevin mccarthy they're whining
about the first amendment freedom of
speech freedom of speech freedom of
speech
while they're on a [ __ ] tv show
in front of a goddamn camera and a
microphone
how much more [ __ ] free speech do you
need to [ __ ] have before you
realize that you're not being censored
you dumb [ __ ]
but i did a little tick tock here so
let's play the tick tock because
you know just like the last one i think
uh have you noticed i think i think it
has some
some uh relevancy here do you ever
notice that there's only enough room
inside these q anon maga trump humper's
thinking space for two amendments and
they don't even know what the [ __ ] those
two say
you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ]
so they can't even put together what the
first amendment the second that's the
ones they talk about all the time
and and i guess it's just because it's
the first two and i
and and maybe it's because they think
the first one lets them
say anything they want and get away with
it and there's no consequences
whatsoever
and then the second one if there is
consequences they'll just kill it with a
gun
i mean i've talked about the second
amendment on here enough the last
several weeks that i'm not even gonna
get into that one
because they're all yapping about the
first one today
and again back to the walmart situation
you do not have the right to paint
whatever you want on the side of
walmart's wall
you do not there are consequences if you
do
what you can do what you can do dummy
is you can go walk beyond walmart's
parking lot you can stand on the public
side
walk in front of walmart and hold you a
cardboard sign that says [ __ ]
walmart you can do that
that is your that's called freedom of
speech that's what it is you can stand
on a public sidewalk with a cardboard
sign that says
[ __ ] walmart
or you can put a sign on your [ __ ]
property in your
yard that's a 4x8 sheet of plywood paint
it nice up
and good and say [ __ ] walmart on that
one
put it in your front yard that way
everyone knows that you want to [ __ ]
walmart
that's your freedom of speech now
here's the next component of the freedom
of speech
let's say you've got a job that doesn't
want you
to put a sign in your front yard that
says [ __ ]
walmart and if you do put a sign in your
front yard that says [ __ ]
walmart they have the right to maybe
maybe just
maybe do something about your employment
that's the consequence of painting up a
4x8 sheet of plywood and
painting [ __ ] walmart i mean
i don't like walmart but i
maybe i should put a [ __ ] walmart sign
in my front yard
but i wouldn't because i'm not a
bonehead
but it's not against your freedom of
speech to keep you from painting
[ __ ] walmart on the side of walmart's
wall
it's not a thing walmart doesn't
have to let you smash their windows
walmart does not have to let you break
their rules
oh here's another one for you [ __ ]
freedom fighters
[ __ ] boneheads is the mask
it's the same thing walmart gets to say
hey you gotta wear a [ __ ] mask to
keep people safe
you gotta wear a [ __ ] shirt you gotta
have [ __ ] pants on you gotta have
[ __ ] shoes on when you come in our
store
it's our store facebook says hey
[ __ ] you gotta put your [ __ ]
shirt on you gotta have [ __ ] pants on
you gotta have your shoes on
and you can't you can't be spreading
that type of [ __ ] hate
mongering and misinformation and lies
and inciting violence on our platform
you can't do it
you're banned [ __ ]
so take it to supreme court charlie kirk
good
luck
oh so next the thing i want to talk
about because i've seen this from the
left and the right
is uh the algorithms and and and big
tech and we need to break up big tech
which i i'm not i'm not exactly against
breaking up a
monopoly and big tech certainly has uh
big monopolies there's a handful of
companies that actually own just about
everything we touch
now facebook google
amazon it did name a few but
but you know everyone wants to blame
everyone wants to blame the algorithms
and there's
several several pieces of content out
there that
that dive into this but listen
the algorithm is an inanimate object an
algorithm
is just a code algorithms are garbage in
garbage out that's what algorithms are
you you as you as a facebook user or
twitter user or tick tock user
you are telling that [ __ ] piece of
artificial intelligence what you want to
see
whether you know it or not whether you
like it or not
you're telling it what you want it to
see you are
you are telling it the garbage that you
want to consume
and the more you consume the garbage
that you like
the more garbage like that they're gonna
feed you
garbage in garbage out that's how it
works that's how the algorithm works
and the only goal of the algorithm on on
tick tock
twitter facebook any of them is to keep
you
on their platform that's the whole point
is to keep you on their platform so they
can
show you billboards and charge people to
show you billboards
that's the whole [ __ ] point
so stopped acting like that's not the
point
so the algorithm is designed to keep you
on their platform
it's designed that way to keep you there
and the way to keep you there is to keep
feeding you [ __ ] that you like that you
want to see that you want to consume
so if you like this q a on [ __ ] this
manga q and on trump hump and [ __ ] it's
gonna feed you that
if you're if you don't like trump if
you're anti-trump
it's going to feed that to you
garbage in garbage out
the algorithm doesn't give a [ __ ] what
you like
it doesn't care it just wants to feed
you what you like
it doesn't care what it is
and you feed it all the signs of what
you like
so when you're scrolling down your
facebook feed and you stop to watch a
video
you watch that video and you watch that
video and you watch that video and then
you scroll on down there's another post
maybe the same
type subject and there's another one and
then you watch that one
and you go down and you click and you
like that one and you do this and you do
that
facebook is taking all that data all of
it that you're doing
not just to like how fast you're
scrolling
how long you watch a post they
the algorithm knows that
if you don't want the algorithm to feed
you a bunch of [ __ ]
stop watching stop looking at a bunch of
[ __ ]
stop i'll give you an example this is a
real world example this is
my example this is why i'm not on
facebook this is why i don't scroll
my news feed on facebook
i used to watch wrestling when i was a
kid and a lot of you gonna pound the
[ __ ] out of me for this
but i like the wcw [ __ ] the wwf that's
what it was called at the time
[ __ ] them now i didn't have any kind of
political reason why not to like the wwf
at the time but
now i kind of do [ __ ] them but the point
is this the wcw
they actually wrestled over there it was
more about the wrestling than the
[ __ ] story lines and i wanted to
watch a bunch of guys
throw each other around and fake
wrestling that's what i wanted to watch
when i was a kid
and my one of my favorite wrestlers was
sting you guys remember sting i think
he's still wrestling jesus christ i
don't know if he's got
crutches or a walker or a wheelchair but
he's still wrestling i think
i don't know for who i don't watch
wrestling anymore but i did when i was a
kid and sting was a very
a very popular wrestler at the time i
really liked him he was my favorite
wrestler especially when he got the
black and white and kind of
the goth look and
and there was a video that i stopped on
facebook
and i watched it was like a like a
little you know a
montage of sting from from beginning of
his career until the
you know the end of his career now right
showed him the different things and all
the stuff that he did and all that [ __ ]
and i watched this video front to back
and then there was another video kind of
about the same thing and i watched a
couple of those
and for [ __ ] weeks for [ __ ] weeks
facebook fed me
professional wrestling [ __ ] and i had to
say no i don't want to watch that i
don't want to watch that i don't i had
to physically tell it i don't want to
watch that
until it finally got out of my feed
because i had put my eyes for a certain
amount of time on professional wrestling
video
that they thought that's what i wanted
to see so they fed it to me garbage in
garbage out the algorithm is not the
problem
folks we are we're the problem
we are the problem
it's us it's human beings
and if someone you know is posting a ton
of [ __ ] just a ton of misinformation
and a ton of [ __ ] it's because they
want to see that [ __ ]
they want to see it they want to see it
they want to believe that garbage
if they if they believe this q and on
stuff they want to believe it
if they're posting it on facebook they
want to believe it that's why facebook
is feed it up to him
now to be fair to be
fair of course some people don't know
that it's not the truth
some people don't know that it's
misinformation because aunt sally posted
on facebook that gives it validity
but that's because they're uneducated
and they don't have all their marbles
our education system has failed us not
the algorithm
not the algorithm it's not it's not the
algorithm's fault
humans are pieces of [ __ ] we are
inherently if you don't believe me
just look at your [ __ ] feed on
facebook
and you're like oh my god why am i why
am i seeing this why am i seeing that
what they're not
testing they're not like oh we'll test
this out on them
no they know what you like based on what
you what you view it
and your the searches that you do
the algorithm isn't bad it's human
beings that are inherently bad
now there is hope there is hope i think
we're getting better
i think people you know they're tired of
the misinformation they're tired of the
[ __ ] lies
they want to know more of the truth
they're closer to the truth they want to
be tethered to some sort of reality
and that's why a lot of people are
leaving social media
not just trumpers i'm not talking about
just trumpers i'm talking about left
right center
they're sick of the algorithm feeding
them the [ __ ]
which there's a way to combat that to
tell the algorithm what to feed you i
don't want that i don't want that i
don't want that i don't want that
you're mistaking algorithm mr algorithm
this isn't what i want to see you think
i want to see this but this isn't what i
want to see
you could tell it to do that you can
tell it
a little button there
garbage in garbage out
it's the algorithm and that's what feeds
us
that's what feeds our society so i don't
think
i don't think that the the facebook al
algorithm is to blame
for a bunch of boneheads out there
believing q a non-conspiracy theories
are believing the big lie or
perpetuating the big lie or somehow
facebook's algorithm is responsible for
the insurrection on january 6.
that's all [ __ ] the people who went
to the capitol on january 6
who didn't have more than two [ __ ]
marbles to realize that they needed to
research a little more
that the vice president couldn't anoint
a king
those were lies and they acted on those
lies
that's not the algorithm's fault it's
not
it's not the algorithm's fault i would
say it's the people perpetuating the
lies fault
who are pumping it into the algorithm
who are feeding the [ __ ] machine
and that's what they did today folks it
brings me to the end here
they put a stop to feeding that [ __ ]
big lie machine today
because they know facebook knows this
this advisory board
knows what would happen if they would
have gave donald trump his access back
to [ __ ] facebook today
it would have been an immediate an
immediate barrage
of spreading this big lie and trying to
convince his base
to act on lies that's what he did his
entire campaign in 2016 that's what he
did the four years he was president
i mean the reason why we had a [ __ ]
prolonged pandemic was because he
constantly was spreading lies about it
and convincing him
his [ __ ] supporters of lies because
he can't do anything else but that
like he's set in line mode
there isn't another trump mode it's
permanently fixed to that mode
i mean think about it last year if
donald trump would have boned up and
realized that the pandemic was real
and masked helped and social distancing
and and and lockdowns could have made us
get out of this pandemic quicker
he would be president of the united
states right now
if in january that [ __ ] bonehead
would have took this seriously and not
acted like it was some sort of
conspiracy out to get him like the
bill gates and anthony fauci to develop
the virus
to send it to wuhan china to release it
so that way they could
the virus could spread around the world
and take down donald trump
if he wouldn't have spread that nonsense
if he would actually spread the idea
that hey this is a real deadly pathogen
it's real
it's going to kill a lot of people and
what we need to do is we need to
we need to listen to the experts here
and i'm going to let the experts help us
make
these health decisions and once we get
over this
idea once we figure out what this is
we'll get the economy back going again
he would be the president of the united
states today today
i believe that if he would have [ __ ]
done his job
got up in the morning put his [ __ ]
shoes on and treated the pandemic like a
[ __ ] pandemic
the country would have went well
at at least he can make us survive a
pandemic because if we would have done
what we were supposed to do
we would have been like all the other
[ __ ] countries around the world that
are now
open and don't have masks and are
basically fully vaccinated if we would
have done what the [ __ ] we were supposed
to do
as opposed to half our [ __ ] country
listen to that bonehead
and believe in what the [ __ ] he said we
would be much better off
we would be where we would need to be
now
which by the way isn't fully fully where
we need to be but god damn we're getting
closer which is exciting
so that's why facebook this the advisory
board decided to do what they did this
today
was to not to make sure that they
weren't going to feed that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
algorithm machine with the big lie
with the nonsense and incite violence
[Music]
and to possibly overthrow other
governments
jesus christ well i'm almost out of time
here did you guys have fun today talking
about social media and facebook
and donald trump's new blog oh my god
he's a blogger now the orange deity is a
blogger
but before i go i do want to tell you i
want to remind everybody
that you should you should seek out and
find if you're not vaccinated yet
you should consider it and you should
right now really you can almost choose
the one you want
um and there's plenty of places to go
and find how to get it where to get it
they're trying to get the vaccine as
close to people as they possibly can
so get vaccinated go get vaccinated
now [ __ ] so do that
get us out of the pandemic do the right
thing uh uh
keep us moving towards the path of
having a full open economy because
that's what we all want
we want to get rid of the mask we don't
want to have to wear the mask
anymore let's let's do this let's get
everyone vaccinated and let's get to
that point
and before i go too if you like the
podcast i appreciate you guys tuning in
if you want to support the podcast you
can buy the [ __ ] hats here at
thetonymichaels.com or you can go to the
merch store
and get you some [ __ ] stickers
there's some coffee mugs over there
there's some shirts
everyone's been buying the hats though
the hats are a big hit i got
gray and black the [ __ ] hats and i
think we're gonna bring some more colors
in
in the next few months so thanks for
everyone out there
that has purchased uh merchandise to
help the podcast stay up here
it does cost money to publish it and a
little bit to produce it mainly it's
just me yelling into a microphone so you
know
but i love you guys come back next week
wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
and i'm sure next week there'll be some
more rudy giuliani news or trump news or
manga news or
liz cheney news god who knows it seems
like a news always drops on wednesday so
until next wednesday [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them